all right uh joe biden has a lot of
problems
one of which is a non-functioning brain
so here's a very real tweet from joe
biden in reference to
uh tropical storm henry he says to those
in henry's path
don't forget that you may need to seek
shelter while we're still battling cover
19 in the delta variant so wear a mask
and try to observe social distancing to
everyone across the country don't get
caught by the next storm get vaccinated
now
wait somehow i i i missed the second
part of this uh the this thing the third
sentence there i missed when i
originally read this
don't get caught by the next storm get
vaccinated now
so what the vaccine is a i would like to
think that he means storm in a
metaphorical sense covet is a storm but
you can never be too sure these days is
he claiming
that the vaccine actually protects
against hurricanes
it really is a wonder drug in that case
i'm not sure if that's what he's
claiming but he is saying
that when planning
for potentially devastating storm
flooding maybe your house is destroyed
uh make sure you wear a mask
that's that should be now it's
interesting here that
if if you got to run to a shelter
because of massive flooding
and um
you know a potentially fatal situation
what he's saying is
make sure to keep in mind social
distancing and wearing masks even even
in the face of an emergency situation
always keep that in mind
and yet if you go back and and you refer
back to the picture
of the afghan
refugees
who are being loaded onto planes in
afghanistan and brought to our
neighborhoods here in the united states
and especially that first picture where
you got 600 afghans and that crowded
onto that plane
and some unfortunately on the outside of
the plane as well
most of them you know young young males
of fighting age but but
no masks among them
i assume there was no covet testing done
there was no requirement for a vaccine
passport
no masks
crowding them onto this plane and
bringing them over here
so in that situation they can say well
we don't have time to worry about any of
that
which makes sense in a vacuum
yeah it would be crazy in in that
situation to worry about oh i gotta make
sure everyone has masks on
and yet for american citizens in an
emergency situation you gotta run to a
shelter with a hurricane bearing down on
your tropical storm buried down you they
want you to worry about the mask
and it's not just uh joe biden we can't
blame only him for this this he is uh
following marching orders from the cdc
because if you go to the cdc page
on preparing for a hurricane
this again is very real
here's what it says preparing for a
hurricane follow these important
hurricane preparedness tips from the cdc
first tip
prepare for a hurricane take basic steps
now to ensure your safety should should
a storm hit i like how their first
the first step in preparing for a
hurricane
is to prepare for a hurricane
prepare for a hurricane step one prepare
for a hurricane oh well thank you cdc
that's that's some some very useful
advice step two
get a covid19 vaccine as soon as you can
so that is
the second thing they want you to do
in preparing for a hurricane is to get
is to get a covered vaccine
again the question is do are they
claiming do they think that the vaccine
actually protects against hurricanes
i would like to assume they can't
possibly be claiming that but i don't
think we can assume that
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content